I have six people in my house that share one bathroom,
and this is what happens to my bathroom.
It's just a cluttered mess,
and it drove me crazy.
So I got the five pack bathroom set from the TikTok shop.
I have it right here. Um,
I really like that I can organize everybody's stuff,
so I can put, like,
mine and the kids stuff in one spot,
our razors in another spot,
my boyfriend stuff up there.
The little racks are metal,
and then they just stick with this little plastic
sticky sheet with hooks on it.
There's plenty of space for everything.
There's five of them, and they're super,
super duper easy to stick.
You just peel off the back,
clean the wall really good,
and then press it on.
And then you have to make sure you get all the air bubbles out
and let it sit for, like,
24 hours. I really do think that's the trick,
because then the hooks are really, really,
really tight. So when you snap it on,
the little baskets aren't gonna go anywhere.
They're not gonna be bouncing around
like the stupid ones that you have to put that, like,
you know, kind of just balance in there.
I love these things. They are amazing.
And now the bathroom feels more organized,
and I can wipe all the surfaces down
and feel like the bathroom is clean,
instead of just having, like,
puddles of water everywhere.
So it's linked Right here in the TikTok shop if you wanna get some